the traditional british summer break is
fast becoming a summer breakdown
cancelled flights delayed baggage
holidays in ruins
rob and his wife samantha were due to be
celebrating their anniversary in spain's
costa del sol when we found out the
flight spin council we were incredibly
disappointed
we had restaurant bookings we had
various things planned during the course
of the weekend
all of which obviously
was completely ruined um
and um our initial thought was to simply
simply go back home and
have a celebration in the uk it was a
very special weekend we'd organized um
planned various things in malaga
and incredibly upset and disappointed a
further wave of cancellations is
expected ahead of a government deadline
on friday part of what's been called a
slot amnesty
at airports like heathrow flight traffic
is governed by a strict system of
takeoff and landing slots in a typical
week heathrow might have something like
9680 slots or 690 departures a day of
those british airways owns more than 50
percent the next biggest airline virgin
atlantic only has four percent but
crucially if an airline doesn't use its
slots it must hand them back
they're highly prized i mean at heathrow
they change hands when they very rarely
come up
for millions of pounds and so airlines
don't want to give up these slots and so
often they will commit to running
flights which they can't feasibly
operate but this is a temporary measure
and the government is saying we'll give
you an amnesty on those slots we'll hand
them back to you at the end of summer
season so you won't lose them in the
long term aside from friday's deadline
the wider causes of the airport chaos
are complex the primary issue is
disruption from the pandemic having cut
jobs when air travel was shut down the
industry has been slow to fill them
again in time to meet surging demand
airlines like easyjet and ryanair have
blamed brexit and the uk's stricter
immigration rules something the
government rejects and then there's the
prospect of looming strike action which
threatens to make matters a great deal
worse
this weekend strikes by easyjet and
ryanair staff have brought airports
across europe to a standstill and
british airways staff at heathrow have
just voted to strike at some point in
the summer
so if you are planning a holiday the
best advice might be to in the words of
your cabin crew brace
brace matthew thompson sky news